[Música]
por primera vez en 16 años alemania va a
elecciones sin la canciller angela
merkel los alemanes eligen al nuevo
parlamento encargado de designar a un
nuevo canciller los candidatos de los
tres principales partidos esperan reunir
el suficiente apoyo para poder formar
gobierno y reemplazar a la mandataria
tenemos informe desde berlín
el gobierno británico ofrecerá más de 10
mil visas de trabajo temporales a
transportistas extranjeros y empleados
de la industria avícola para paliar la
escasez de mano de obra que tiene
afectada a la cadena de suministro en el
país principalmente el combustible el
gobierno pidió calma ante las largas
filas en las gasolinerías
se cumplen siete años de la desaparición
de los 43 estudiantes en china para en
la víspera el gobierno de mexico mandó
una carta a israel para pedir la
extradición de tomás cerón al
exfuncionario se le acusa de ocultar
pruebas durante la investigación que
dirigía cuando enrique peña nieto era
presidente del país
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos en alemania
que hoy celebra elecciones generales en
las que por primera vez en 16 años la
canciller angela merkel no figura como
candidata más de 60 millones de
ciudadanos están llamados a las urnas
para escoger al parlamento los
candidatos de tres principales partidos
esperan reunir los suficientes votos
para formar gobierno y reemplazar a la
mandataria sin embargo las últimas
proyecciones apuntan a que habrá un
resultado bastante cerrado entre la
unión demócrata cristiana de merkel los
socialdemócratas de centroizquierda y el
partido verde para ampliar esta noticia
vamos hasta berlín con nuestro
corresponsal tomas sparrow toma muy
buenos días y cuéntenos cómo transcurre
esta jornada
la jornada transcurre hasta el momento
sin mayores sobresaltos quizás excepto
en la ciudad de bupa tal donde una bomba
de la segunda guerra mundial fue
encontrada y tuvo que ser desactivada y
mientras eso ocurría pues las personas
no pudieron asistir a los puestos de
votación sin embargo la ciudad de bumba
tal explicó hace poco que ya todo fue
desactivado y que vuelve a la normalidad
el resto en berlín y en otras partes de
alemania la jornada continúa con
normalidad los principales candidatos
como la sol su amiga 7 ya depositaron
sus votos la canciller angela merkel
decidió hacerlo por correo así que no
habrá una foto de angela merkel frente a
las urnas hoy quizás ella no quería ser
el centro de atención en este domingo de
elecciones en el que se determinará la
composición del nuevo parlamento alemán
y también en últimas quién será el
sucesor de merkel luego de esos 16 años
al frente de alemania thomas
precisamente cuando sabremos quién
sucederá angela merkel
esa es la gran pregunta hace cuatro años
en las elecciones de 2017 la formación
de gobierno duró cinco meses y el país
ahora está mucho más polarizado que en
ese entonces entonces los expertos
esperan que esa formación de gobierno
también pueda durar bastante tiempo hoy
después de que se cierren las urnas lo
que se sabrá es la fortaleza de los
diferentes partidos políticos y con base
en esa fortaleza los principales líderes
de esos partidos se sentarán a negociar
el acuerdo de oposición el acuerdo de
coalición en últimas también determinará
quién será el canciller de alemania
thomas sparrow con la información desde
berlín las elecciones de alemania la
noticia que estaremos desarrollando a lo
largo de nuestros informativos cambiamos
de tema y pasamos a reino unido donde se
han visto largas filas en las
gasolinerías que han tenido que cerrar
ante la falta de abastecimiento la
cadena de suministro se ha visto
afectada en el país debido a la escasez
de mano de obra que golpea a diversos
sectores y fue provocada por el break
city la pandemia de kobe 19 para aliviar
la crisis el gobierno británico anunció
que ofrecerá más de 10 mil visas de
trabajo temporal a transportistas
extranjeros
me temo que una de las asociaciones de
transporte por carretera y un informe
bastante irresponsable que contribuyó a
desencadenar una crisis y eso es muy
poco útil
y es contraproducente y sé que están
desesperados por tener más conductores
europeos que socaven los salarios
británicos esa ha sido su intención
desde el principio oscuro lo pasamos a
méxico porque hoy se cumple el séptimo
aniversario del caso ayotzinapa el
gobierno mandó una carta a israel para
pedir la extradición de tomás serón a
quien se le acusa del ocultamiento de
pruebas durante su investigación en el
gobierno de enrique peña nieto- a pesar
de que el presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador se ha comprometido
a esclarecer lo ocurrido desde su
campaña los familiares de los
desaparecidos afirman que no ha habido
suficientes avances informe de manuel a
cano
en silencio y con carteles de sus
desaparecidos así caminaban los
familiares de 43 jóvenes estudiantes de
ayotzinapa de quienes no se saben su
paradero desde septiembre de 2014 siete
años después del caso las familias han
recalcado la falta de avances en la
investigación a pesar de que en su
mayoría reconocen el compromiso de la
nueva administración de andrés manuel
lópez obrador como muestra de su
cometido el gobierno mexicano pidió la
extradición desde israel de toma cerón
quien dirigió la investigación durante
el mandato de enrique peña nieto y al
que se le acusa de haber ocultado
pruebas incluso el presidente de la
república ha enviado una carta que
pronto dará a conocer en cual se
confirme que ha sido recibida por el
primer ministro de israel
solicitando su apoyo y colaboración el
testimonio de serón a quien también se
le señala de tortura es una de las
muchas piezas que faltan para
reconstruir el rompecabezas del caso de
ayotzinapa entre los que está esclarecer
la responsabilidad del ejército la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos
apuntó a que su presencia en la noche de
los hechos posiblemente fue mayor de lo
estimado anteriormente
vemos que hay algunos avances en la
investigación pero también a los ojos de
los padres pues no se ha establecido con
claridad el paradero de los de los
jóvenes de los estudiantes y hay muchos
obstáculos que están presentando algunas
instituciones como la fiscalía general
la secretaria de la defensa nacional
algunas de las cifras del avance de la
investigación son desalentadoras de las
casi 90 órdenes de captura se han
llevado a cabo menos de 50 y sólo se han
identificado en los restos de tres de
los 43 desaparecidos
en nicaragua la campaña presidencial
para las elecciones de noviembre comenzó
oficialmente este sábado pero con los
principales rivales de daniel ortega
bajo arresto los resultados de las
elecciones son para muchos predecibles
la autoridad electoral de nicaragua
permitió participar a cinco partidos
desconocidos para desafiar al presidente
que aspira a una nueva reelección
suban las manos bendiciones gritan estos
seguidores del partido cristiano
nicaragüense para ellos solo dios podría
hacer ganar la presidencia a su
candidato guillermo osorno el pastor
evangélico de esta iglesia
osorno es uno de los cinco candidatos de
derecha a quienes las autoridades
permitieron realizar campaña contra el
presidente daniel ortega
todos los partidos opositores a los que
se les permitió correr en la contienda
electoral son desconocidos y tienen poca
o ninguna posibilidad de ganar porque no
podemos hacer caravana de vehículo en
campaña ni - de grupos ni menos de
pararse en una esquina con la foto de
los candidatos a presentarlo aunque la
campaña presidencial comenzó el sábado
las elecciones han perdido credibilidad
según el secretario de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken
ortega de 75 años busca su cuarto
mandato consecutivo junto a su esposa
como vicepresidente en mayo de este año
el gobierno del ex guerrillero
sandinista arrestó a los principales
candidatos de la oposición incluida su
principal rival cristiana chamorro
la policía también endureció sus medidas
contra la libertad de prensa pero ir a
votar envía un mensaje poderoso asegura
walter espinoza un candidato desconocido
a quien se le permitió postularse y está
consciente que si aquí no votamos
masivamente el 7 de noviembre aquí se
van a prestar al juego del continuismo
tras la violenta represión a las
protestas antigubernamentales de 2018
eeuu y la unión europea han impuesto
sanciones a funcionarios del gobierno el
mes pasado hicieron un llamado al
retorno de la democracia en nicaragua
vamos a españa' pues continúa la
actividad del volcán cumbre vieja en la
isla de la palma tras la apertura de
nuevas bocas y la rotura del cono
volcánico el volcán arrojó miles de
toneladas de lava lo que ocasionó el
cierre del aeropuerto de la región los
desechos volcánicos destruyeron cientos
de casas y forzaron la evacuación de
casi 6.000 personas sin embargo las
autoridades han hecho un llamado a la
calma y dijeron que se trata de una
típica erupción hasta el momento no se
han reportado víctimas mortales ni
heridos graves
y terminamos este informativo con música
porque la copa mundial de tango de
buenos aires ya tiene nuevos campeones
la edición de este año marcó el regreso
del festival después de que se realizara
una versión en línea en 2020 a raíz de
la emergencia provocada por el kobe 19
el tango género musical que incluye la
danza música poesía y canto fue
declarado en 2009 patrimonio cultural
inmaterial de la humanidad por la unesco
[Música]
por estas imágenes despedimos este
informativo en france 24 quédense con
nosotros
[Música]